this is a production of cornell
university
yeah let's get it started um thanks
everyone this is the last episode this
year the cornell turf show our spring
series at least episode 19.
you've been with us for 10 weeks and
this is our last sports episode our
guest today dr chase straw from texas a
m uh you've uh if you've been a loyal
listener or watcher you'll remember
chase from past seasons
uh we're gonna have a good sports
conversation from everything everything
from precision turf management on sports
fields down to the community
sports field level uh we'll try and
cover a bunch of a bunch of topics in
the fastest 30 minutes in turf um so as
always frank i'll let you get it started
with a little weather recap and yeah
yeah i gotta i got a good setup today
chase you're doing some really
fascinating work that one of the great
joys of prepping for these things is
finding out what my colleagues are doing
so it was great fun uh reading the work
you have in there recently so uh big
shout out uh our last uh show
of our third season and and you know as
as carl said chase has been with us uh a
couple of times all of us that like
speaking into the ether
uh you know doing this show um always
appreciate sports turf managers taking a
lot of pride in their work this is a uh
sports turf manager uh doing a really
cool logo in the outfield i i think you
know i i've always been like you know a
lot of people get into this profession
to you know be in the background and not
draw attention
and i think there's a place for just
going about your job and one of the
things i think a lot of us like about
this work is is a lot of it is that you
don't have to worry about a lot of
different things that maybe other jobs
do but at the same time
i think promoting the things we do in
cool ways like this attracts people to
the industry especially young people
that want to try
using technology and doing different
things so a simple logo like this is
also a way of recruiting young people
and then and then you got these two
knuckleheads who think that they should
be doing uh sports turf work i got a
little bit more respect for the for adam
wainwright than i do for the knucklehead
on the right i don't think the guy on
the right could cut a straight line if
his life depended on it so i don't think
we're taking up gronkowski anytime soon
to pick up lawn mowing but i gotta tell
you chase uh one more funny thing and
we'll set up carl for the stat of the
day
um you guys take your high school
football pretty seriously uh down in
texas
and um we're lucky we can get a two
million dollar uh bond for uh a track in
a field and um this this thing in
mckinney texas made the new york times
about four or five years ago it got
built and had a little bit of trouble
but i think it was fascinating um
[Music]
and carl this sets you up for youth
yeah
so so frank you're showing slides there
63 million dollar high school football
field facilities almost 70 million
dollars
and i think you know a lot of this comes
back when we talk about youth sports
participation a lot of people listening
we'll sort of know the the uh benefits
from having youth participate in sports
and there's a couple studies here that
looked at
um cardio metabolic health profile
that's everything from weight and an
ability to sustain cardio activities
12 years after they played
sports in middle school and high school
they saw that that folks who who
participated in organized youth sports
maintain those benefits you can also
find
youth benefits in mental health and
lower depression if they play organized
sports
so that's really good there's a lot of
reasons to get your kids into sports
but unfortunately it's not equal access
among all the the kids in in our uh
and even in our state but across the
country uh so you can see here a little
bar graph of household income
and the percentage of
uh youth who participate uh in those
brackets so if you're below the poverty
level only about 40 percent of kids and
households like that participate in
youth sports if you go to four times
that
uh income level that increases to almost
80 percent right so we we don't have
even participation
among income levels in with kids and and
that's really connected to sort of the
uh access to
public areas uh green spaces baseball
fields you you see here and another
study said that investing in those local
facilities can improve
participation of communities in need so
it's it's certainly something i think we
all kind of know about but it really
places the importance on public access
green spaces i have problems with with
finding basketball courts for our for
our basketball team special olympics
basketball so i can't imagine with uh
with organized uh football teams
baseball young kids
trying to get around and find places for
those kids to to play sports yeah you
know carl i i tell you there's a couple
of things and we're going to actually
get right at this because chase has
played around in this area particularly
the disparity sometimes uh that gets
called out in his in that recent paper
we're going to talk about but but the
data is a place to start and even if
you're just managing sports field you
say oh you know i just cut the grass or
i do this or do that you know justifying
and and making sure we're meeting the
needs of the participants is our job but
at the same time we can be advocates
for these things and a lot of times
sports field managers can be those kind
of people that facilitate these
conversations because a lot of times
they get pretty heated i would imagine
and chase we'll get to talk about that
in a minute but let's talk about we're
going to get to the heat we're going to
get some heat up here uh in the
northeast but we'll start out with this
moisture for sports field managers a lot
of a lot of seasons are wrapping up
spring seasons are wrapping up a lot of
people are looking at soil management
programs uh for non-sand-based systems
uh even for sand based systems that
might get rolled and and beat up a
little bit um you can see over the last
month
there's a quite a bit of dry area
throughout the northeast you've got some
really hard gradients from pennsylvania
border south a lot of above 100
normal precipitation and then as soon as
you get above the pennsylvania line and
you get into new england and northern
new england except for the far reaches
of northern new england and new
hampshire vermont and upstate new york
you're pretty dry so the soils actually
will be a little bit on the dry day up
to this point in the last month or a
little bit on the dry side so that makes
them good for working now last week
total precipitation was about a half to
an inch depending on where you were and
now that evapotranspiration if you look
at this you can see water loss you know
the sun pulling the water out of the
earth uh is driving up into the one to
1.25 levels in some places now along the
coast metropolitan new york area they're
not losing as much water
and a little bit of rainfall
won't i mean they won't be getting uh
they'll be getting a little bit of
rainfall this weekend that should help
with that
so
what are we expecting uh where what did
we just get in the last few days when we
look at precip minus uh
evapotranspiration again uh some dry
areas throughout new england and
northern new york uh some a little
wetter areas in delmarva but looking
forward it's again looking like it's a
balance it's not going to be too wet
it's not going to be too dry so from
managing soils
this could be a good time
to get those soils cultivated if you
want to do anything some top dressing
and take advantage of a couple of weeks
with some good weather before the real
uh persistent heat come starts coming
now soil temperatures are really well
into the 50s and 60s so there shouldn't
be any problem getting grass seed to
grow now uh in these areas so it's good
timing in a lot of ways to start working
the soil on some of these sports fields
now to air temperature we are still on
the roller coaster we can see the up and
down we're not going down
as much now we're not getting down as
cool uh as we've been now we're going to
see a big shift to this because we're
going to go up the other way
right now last week we were about 10 to
12 degrees uh above normal uh out you
know as certainly as you get into
northern new england and growing degree
days that that change in heat where it
was warmer up north and cooler down
south last week it has a real uh
neutralizing effect on the growing
season it's helped the north catch up
and it's kept the south at normal but
right around we're about a week of
normal now one side or the other about a
week behind or a week ahead of normal
conditions
for the middle of middle of may
and it looks like the news coming out is
that we're going to get stinking hot uh
this weekend we're going to be into the
90s creeping up into the upper 90s which
is nothing for our friend in the south
there
to get into the 90s but obviously the
outlook and the growing degree days look
at the accumulation growing degree days
which we would have been happy a few
weeks ago if we would have gotten 40 or
50 a week in the new york metropolitan
area philly area you're going to be over
100 to 150
growing degree days for the week so you
know you're talking about 20 degrees
above average temperatures 20 degrees
above 50. so 70 degree average
temperatures during the day
for the next several days to accumulate
these things now
what that means and this is the
transition uh
chase into the conversation what this
means for us in the northeast is we're
gonna actually experience our first what
we call uh heat stress the the
combination of uh air temperatures and
humidity particularly for persistent for
more than eight hours you can see it's
starting to stretch up into the moderate
level in the new york metropolitan area
philly up to hudson valley
out towards boston and you know
chase as i bring you in you know one of
the things you just did uh is measure
this but really from a fascinating
perspective i thought um this is a uh
article i got out of sports field
managers it should be a research article
i don't i don't know if you put this in
the literature or not but it certainly
is worthy of it it is
looking at player perceptions
right and using that as a measure of
thermal stress and so you have a lot of
measurements you set up different uh
microclimates you know they played on
different days and during the games when
they were playing you would ask them
questions about perceived surface
temperature perceived thermal comfort
and then you
translated it to this confascours right
you you asked them about these these how
they perceived it and this is where
you're gonna have this is what i'm gonna
bring in you're gonna have to talk to us
a little bit about this chart work here
right where you looked at energy budget
um and essentially you know this is very
complicated but here's how i read it i
read it as um
the players basically perceived
stress
in the very dangerous level
on these synthetic surfaces we would
have liked all of those lines to be in
the cream colored
section whereas they wound up in the
dark brown section so let's take a
minute now leave it here talk to us a
little bit about
doing this kind of work working with
athletes and then getting this
information because natural turf didn't
fare so well either which i think was
surprising so let's talk a little bit
about this
yeah you know and a lot of this research
was new to me and you all are pretty
familiar with my work frank and carl a
lot of the work that i do is
interdisciplinary so
some of these things are really hard to
explain even for me right
so
i'm scratching my head but yeah you know
i was really surprised about the turf
grass field being within that extremely
danger zone but i mean that just goes to
show you
just ambient air temperature how much of
an influence that can have on on
people's perceived thermal stress and
you know the the big take away from this
is that artificial turf can decrease or
i'm sorry natural turf grass can
decrease uh the players perceive thermal
stress by about 20
during the hottest times of the year um
so so on artificial turf
20 they perceive that field to be at
least 20 hotter and in my mind
that's going to affect a lot of things
right um and it's going to affect a lot
of things that we've actually measured
as part of this study that we're
actually going to write for a peer
review publication things like rate of
dehydration so we measured a bunch of
dehydration measurements throughout all
these games
performance you all know that i like the
gps trackers so we monitored their
performance their distance ran um all of
these different things tie together and
how does it influence them from a
physiological standpoint but also from
the performance standpoint um and that's
it's the results are really interesting
we're writing that paper right now and i
really look forward to getting that
published okay so you all right wait you
can't leave us there brother give us
some teasers what kind of things are you
finding and i gotta say it's so great
that you're doing this this this
you know transdisciplinary
interdisciplinary work um
and things like who think a turf person
involved in rate of dehydration but by
working with these people you can get
that so you can give us a little preview
to the paper yeah so yeah so the the
rate of dehydration was really
surprising to me so basically what we
found out was there was not a
significant difference in that rate of
dehydration but the trend was as you
expected
so starting out pre-match we measured
their body weight and then at the end of
each quarter we broke these games up in
the quarter we did six simulated soccer
matches um and we had a non-hydration
and a hydration group so we had groups
to compare
the non-hydration group was a group they
get they were able to drink water
between quarters and all that the
hydration group they didn't drink
anything the entire game
uh and so we measured at the end of each
quarter their body weight so we could
get that change in body weight uh they
did p samples for urine specific gravity
yeah yeah i mean we did it all i didn't
do it
um but but the trends are really
interesting so so you know
in a nutshell there was no difference
but the trend was there
artificial turf the the rate was faster
it's just that that difference was was
not significant um now with that said
this was in september in texas
august was a hotter month instead than
september this has just happened when we
when we did the study
and it was only through six simulated
matches so if we were to do more
you know maybe that separation starts to
split but you know the trend in
performance and in the rate of
dehydration is what you expected as well
as the game continued on
that separation started getting bigger
and bigger so it's worse on synthetic
than natural grass exactly exactly
so you know really interesting results
to tie all of this together um and uh
you know
i'm focused on a little bitty portion of
this study but we're we're piecing all
the all the different groups together
and we're hoping fingers crossed you
know how this is frank trying to get a
publication in by the end of summer
we've been working on it for a year
that's right so so okay a couple of
things right because now the setup the
setup for me
you know it's a perfect setup for this
other work that you did
because you know as you and i know
everybody who gets involved in turf
extension work in any state is going to
get
should i put a natural field in or a
synthetic field then right and and i
would see that context of having that
data doing that interdisciplinary work
understanding things at a really high
level
becomes part of this work in putting
communities together now let me
introduce this particular topic because
you publish this paper with a lot of
other people who
who are not turf people and wanted to
look at what i can tell you can become
one of the most contentious issues in
new york never mind in texas where
they'll spend 70 million dollars on a
freaking album i mean i mean and in
texas they can bring guns to these
meetings that's embarrassing by the way
that's crazy and i know
so i'm trying to talk about this in a
lighthearted way but i'm sure that a lot
of people in texas don't take this in a
lighthearted way so you put together
this really nice uh collection of
information that tries to set up the way
a community uh might approach this right
the way of bringing people together to
use data like you're generating from the
athlete's perspective you know you look
at footwear like sorakan and mcnit do on
okay how do you help people pick
footwear and then what i loved is that
you know you introduced this thing
around uh you know hey this is a thing
for the world it's not just you know the
united states sports is a way of
actually bringing people together giving
access to other people the united
nations has gotten involved the sports
development for peace i thought this was
i spent a couple hours just looking into
this stuff i was so fascinated by it but
when i look at it you know i think about
what they put in the u.n and i look at
the paper that you did here and when i
look at these things that kids benefit
from right having this athletic stuff
like carl showed in the data and you're
testing hey what's the best surface for
them to be on it almost seems petty to
try to argue synthetic or natural turf
let's just give these kids a place to
play
how did this piece of work come about
and how are you able to start to think
about using it and facilitating it in
your work chase is is really the
question for me and i'll just stop and
we'll look at each other now um how do
you how do you take this
work and start to put it into action as
an extension specialist and for our
sports to real managers listening to
this thing what are the takeaways for
them with some of this information
yeah
yeah well you know it all started
it's been a slow trickle for me and
we're building up to where we finally
have this publication because you know
in grad school a lot of the work that i
did was on community level fields
all the literature that i read i just
started to recognize it's all at the
professional level it's all at the
collegian level you know there's just
not that information out there and then
as i go to all my research sites to do
all my work i'm talking to these guys
and i'm hearing these conversations
about what they're having and what
they're having to deal with in some
situations i mean college stations
building a new uh artificial turf
baseball park
and you know the field manager the
director of grounds he didn't even know
about it he was not based in that
decision whatsoever
you hear it all the time it happened to
kentucky you know where i'm from uh when
they converted from grass to artificial
turf uh they didn't let the sports field
manager know that they were converting
it just happened um and you know that's
just
us our side the turf side you know what
other opinions especially at that
community level are not getting
considered like what other what other uh
factors aren't being put to play and you
know we always think about these acute
injuries you know heat is obviously a
big thing with artificial turf and grass
but there's the accessibility
um you know because i would assume that
joe schmoe can't walk on that 74 million
dollar football field that's exactly
right brother
that's exactly right so if the community
is investing that much money into their
football field you know what about the
other fields at the middle schools and
the elementary schools and all of that
there's got to be a trade-off right and
there's no data out there there's no
there's no information on how these
decisions get made there's no data or
tool which is something that works well
okay wait okay i'll give you some data
you want some data one town says they
got a 40 million dollar field i want a
60 million dollar field or in our case
they'll say well this really nice
lacrosse school in westchester county
new york
is synthetic it's a badge of honor to
have a synthetic turf field and again
you know i look at it like
how much use are you getting
like i could argue for a synthetic field
i could argue against the synthetic
field depending on the context when you
look at these things chase and you peel
back and the ground's manager isn't
involved who is making these decisions
business managers the people with the
money right it's the money it's the
money people right
um but but you know in today's world and
you know maybe not so much in texas as
new as new york but the whole
environmental factor too right the heat
you build these things next to buildings
the artificial turf there's you know
there's research how you can influence
all of that you know uh the green spaces
the car the whole issue with carbon now
and urban yeah i mean it's all tied
together right and to me to just make
the call because
the county over did it so let's do it or
because we can play a few more games on
it you know they're really not putting
full thought into that and that's kind
of where this whole the whole paper came
from and you know i
i started to piece together people at
the university of minnesota when i was
there to to do this because and the nice
thing about that is we're in a bigger
city we had uh the national sports
center it's one of the biggest soccer
complexes in the country is uh north of
minneapolis so we had basically hundreds
of fields at our disposal that we could
do research on with actual people
and i left and came to texas and then i
met a whole another group of people that
could do this stakeholder network stuff
of tying people together where are their
gaps in decision making where's their uh
who's not being considered uh things
like well okay so there's where i'm
gonna get you now this is area that you
know you and i scientists don't venture
into very often it can be a contentious
issue nowadays because we've politicized
uh diversity equity inclusion stuff
but it is absolutely clear as day i can
tell you
as a white guy i do a lot of listening i
i try to listen right because we've been
talking too much but one of the things i
will say is when i go in there there's
not a lot of diversity making that
decision either and when they're
thinking about spending all that money
it's not necessarily for the poor kids
or it's not necessarily for the black
and brown kids and i can tell you from
talking to architects in new york city
who've worked for the city parks people
and they said he put a park in a black
neighborhood and it's got basketball
courts and no grass they put a park in a
white neighborhood and it's a lot of
grass fields right those sorts of things
and i don't think anybody intentionally
does this
no i don't think there's a person who
actually thinks oh they're black let's
do this are they white let's do that
it's a cultural thing how have you got
god's name began to approach this uh in
a place like texas
i've wrote a paper
that's where we are now so you know i
was telling you uh in an email this past
week you know we're gonna start bringing
stakeholders in
uh in minnesota and texas that's where
we're starting and we're gonna bring in
the park director people we're going to
bring in hopefully some people that make
decisions at isd city council people and
we're going to figure out how they bring
these people in to make decisions you
know it's i don't know and it's probably
going to vary right it's going to vary
based on whatever city or whatever
um but we need to figure that out so
that we can start figuring out better
ways to bring in more people to get more
in in a logical way right a lot of these
people they're on timelines everything's
timeline now right you got to get it
right
you got to get it done so how can we how
can we
basically develop this tool
that can help communities
reach to those voices who are unheard
and include them into that conversation
in a logical manner to where their voice
is actually con actually considered too
not just there to talk you know
this is
you know so now you're into something
right where you know what is the role as
a sports field manager right as you just
indicated so brilliantly they're usually
the last ones to know about things how
does the you know like our regular
listener ben palmer in the city of west
and massachusetts how does someone who's
working at a school district
get more involved in the conversation
because you know we're turf people a lot
of us get into this line of work because
we don't necessarily want to be involved
in these conversations i don't think you
find a ton of people people
in our turf field because we ride mowers
and we work in fields and we tend to do
those things so even interacting with
coaches and athletes can be tricky for
us sometimes as a population and i'm not
disparaging that we can it's just
sometimes our personalities don't align
with that work where does a sports field
manager start chase in trying to get
this going before you know we get you
figured out all these things what's a
couple of simple tips you give people
listening for where to get started with
this
you know i think the
the interdisciplinary research that it's
becoming just so common now like
it's it's more the research that comes
out of our industry now is more than
just
mowing high water use it better be you
know uh because the people you know turf
is just such a major part of society and
people don't even realize it that's
right and so i would dig into these the
literatures i mean in sports field
management magazine they come up with
they're starting to incorporate new
research that's part of part of the
editorial we're trying to get more
research in there you know really dive
into the literature the things that are
going on across the country and just be
aware of that and how people are
obviously they talk most people talk to
their colleagues and all that but the
literature of the data especially this
interdisciplinary stuff that shows how
turf impacts turf grass and artificial
turf impact society like know that stuff
because it's going to be important and
it's going to give you fuel
i don't want to say fuel but it's going
to give you you know a conversation
point a talking point with maybe
somebody that doesn't understand and
then with the tools and technologies
with the mapping and the data all of
that can be hard for people to do i
totally get it but that's just another
way you can use a quantifiable number
hard data to either make a point or to
to
you know show something well and let me
so okay so all that said uh we're
getting close to wrapping up i want to
tie it back to the synthetic turf thing
it looks like if i was looking at your
data correctly it doesn't really matter
what that surface temperature is even if
the grass is a little cooler those
athletes at certain times are at danger
are in danger and that's not what i
think a lot of people think i think they
most people think like you described
with the hydration experiment that the
gap is much wider
right than it actually is
um with that as a backdrop you know
super you know grounds managers can't
necessarily say
synthetic turf is is is that bad right i
mean
injecting yourself into that part of the
conversation had to be surprising
finding out that the athletes perceive
it different but it's still troublesome
do you see sports field managers
assertively going out and saying hey
i got data that says it's going to be a
tricky day even on the grass today
do you think we got enough people around
these kids at these school levels to
take care of their health and well-being
because you've identified it is somebody
tending to it
they need to uh and they're the web bulb
globe temperature
is what is typically considered uh
ambient temperature you don't want to
use because the surface temperature is
going to be so different we show that in
the paper
um
they they need to and you know one thing
that i've learned from all this too is
that
you know it's common sense i just
haven't thought about it is the youth
are more susceptible to the heat right
so you know we did collegiate athletes
so basically adults
um you throw a 10 year old
eight-year-old some of these younger
kids out there in that heat that danger
zone is going to go way up even on grass
even on grass yeah and this is in
september that's another thing and you
know year-round artificial turf that's
not true especially in texas there's
months here this month has been too hot
for people so i mean there's places that
shut down because it's too hot and it's
not 24 7. it might be more durable but
it's not 24 7 and you do need to
strongly consider that heat the surface
temperature
chase i think i could talk to you all
day about this especially bringing in
these other disciplines carl and i talk
about this all the time i'm done with
moen height work you know what i mean
i'm done with comparing one fertilizer
to another one grass type to another
there's a lot of people doing that work
still and it's i'm not disparaging it
it's important work but i don't think
it's going to advance this industry in a
way it needs to be as as much as you're
doing that's why i keep bugging you carl
get us out of here chase thanks so much
yeah thanks chase again uh really
insightful like frank says we could
listen all day about this sort of thing
and this you know these recordings if
you guys are watching on youtube or
listening on a podcast these are great
things to to pass on to maybe the people
making decisions and so they can read
this this sort of paper that really
outlines
a framework and and sounds like chase
you're going to try and uh test out test
out that framework and see how well it
goes i'm sure it will change so he's
guaranteed to be back for season four
carl right that's right uh thanks
everyone our live audience all year long
thank you guys for joining uh people
listed on the podcast or youtube uh you
know let us know how we did would you
like to see different things are we
idiots are we talking about we're
talking idiots
give us some feedback yeah call us names
whatever you want to do but leave some
feedback for us uh thank you for for
being with us for season three of the
cornell turf show we'll be back probably
later in the season with a couple uh
odds and ends episode
pop-up episodes but until then uh take
care everybody
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu